this next story has absolutely exploded
and it's as detailed as it is disgusting
as we're discussing today a whole bunch
of companies are working on corona virus
vaccines that's a good thing one of the
companies is a German medical company
named cure vac there are now widespread
reports with corroboration that Donald
Trump offered a billion dollars to this
company to secure the vaccine for the
United States only now the reaction from
Trump fists was totally predictable
first they denied it was true fake news
fake news fake news oh it's been
confirmed by German officials and
authorities well they said good for
Trump he's watching out for us
America first which is exactly what you
would imagine a trumpet would say about
this so let's go through the details
Trump was interested in buying this
future of possible vaccine for the
United States for a billion dollars this
became known inside of Germany to the
point that the German government was
almost negotiating against Trump
offering money to the company so that
the vaccine would stay in Germany and be
available to everyone as it should be if
and when it is ready to go Germans were
understandably outraged the world is
understandably outraged Trump wanted to
get the vaccine here and only here
somehow
to help him politically that's what this
is about that's what Donald Trump was
trying to do now of course US officials
can't deny the story because it's been
corroborated so widely what they're
saying is it's been misreported for
example US officials are saying we're
talking to lots of companies who are
working on vaccines and we can offer
money to them to help them of course
that's not what this what this is and
any solution that is found they say
should be shared with the world what
they're not saying is would it be shared
with the whole world at the same time or
would the United States get at first the
giving Trump the opportunity to announce
I got us the vaccine Americans are
getting vaccinated before anybody else
now adding to the intrigue here last
week this company cure vac weirdly an
they were changing CEOs this was unusual
CEO Daniel Mann akela was replaced by
Ingmar hora just weeks after men akela
met with Donald Trump the hypothesis is
and again this part is more speculative
the hypothesis is that men akela may
actually have been willing to accept the
billion dollars from Trump to give the
vaccine only or at least first to the
United States the board and stockholders
of Kure vac caught wind of it fired the
guy put in a different CEO and said very
clearly if we are successful in
developing a vaccine it should help and
protect the entire world the German
Health Minister spon said that a
takeover of cure back by the Trump
administration is quote off the table
that cure vac will only develop a
vaccine for the whole world not for
individual countries look at where the
world is today Donald Trump offering
cash to give him the vaccine to let him
get the benefit and of course after
denying that this happened his
supporters predictably started saying
hey this is good
Trump's President of the United States
Trump is not president of Italy Trump is
not president of Germany his first
priority should be get us the vaccine
but of course this is as immoral as it
is stupid the disease didn't start in
the US yet we are now increasingly
ravaged by it vaccinating only Americans
wouldn't help since no vaccine is 100%
effective not everyone would get the
vaccine and the disease would simply
keep spreading if only Americans were
vaccinated this is aside from this being
utterly disgusting it's also very very
short-sighted this is that that's sort
of dumb America first mentality that's
not only immoral but it's also ad otic
in this case and as I read this I
realized you know if Trump wasn't born
to a rich family instead of trying to
buy a vaccine for a billion bucks from
Germany he'd be the guy buying the hand
sanitizer in order to start price
gouging by then selling it at 30 or 40
bucks a pop understand that Germans are
shocked and appalled by this people in
Germany can't understand how is Trump
even a person that exists in the world
never mind how is he President of the
United States and sadly these low
information trumpets who see him as
unable to do any wrong say love it
go Trump make America great again keep
America great again
it's a nightmare hellscape of
embarrassment made worse every day and
just if to put a final point on this
imagine for a second the reverse
situation imagine a pandemic was
spreading all over the world and it
turned out that a US company had a
vaccine ready to go and imagine that the
US company sold rights to the vaccine to
I don't know Italy or Germany or France
or China or Russia or whoever and maybe
later they'd make it available to
Americans the same people who are saying
don't regulate businesses and what a
good job Trump is doing trying to get us
the vaccine would be saying take over
that business put the executives in
prison it is a disgusting double
standard it's truly a stunning story and
my guess is over the next few days we'll
learn a lot more about the details make
sure you're following me on Twitter for
all the latest kovat 19 updates a lot is
happening on my Twitter account at D
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this